Hey there, I’m Mike Rugnetta, this is Crash
Course Theater, and today we’re taking on
the theater of Renaissance England.
Which means Shakespeare, right?
Wrong, unfortunately.
It’ll be a bit before we know of poor Yorick.
Get thee to the ceiling, pal.
Believe it or not, there are Renaissance English
plays and playwrights and theaters and troupes
that existed totally independent of Shakespeare.
Well, mostly independent of Shakespeare.
Today we’ll discuss historical context,
introduce the English playhouse, and meet
some early plays and playwrights.
And we’re not going to talk about Shakespeare!
Not at all.
It’s gonna be much ado about something…
else.
INTRO
The Renaissance arrives in England… late.
Really late.
Like 150 years later than Italy-late.
Why?
Well, there are a bunch of reasons, but mostly
England spent a lot of the late Middle Ages
embroiled in the Hundred Years’ War with
France, which obviously lasted one hundred
and sixteen years, and then thirty two more
years fighting the Wars of the Roses, a series
of civil wars for control of England, which
involved far fewer actual roses than you may
expect.
Once the Tudors took the throne, things got
more stable.
Humanism and the scientific method and madrigals
really took off.
The Tudors liked theater.
Like, really liked it a lot.
Henry VII, the first Tudor king, paid for
court entertainments.
His son Henry VIII, the one with all the wives,
established an independent Office of the Revels,
managed by a Master of Revels whose job it
was to arrange plays and masques for the nobility.
There were definitely some plays the Tudors
didn’t like.
England had been Catholic and then Protestant
and then Catholic and then Protestant again,
and sometimes plays could be used to fan the
flames of religious discord.
So in 1558, Henry’s daughter Elizabeth I
cracked down on religious and political plays.
This pretty much ended the cycle plays.
She also passed a law classifying actors as
vagrants who could be fined for going from
town to town.
The solution?
Troupes of actors hooked up with nobility
and licensed themselves as servants under
names like The Lord Chamberlain’s Men and
The Lord Admiral’s Men.
Jeez, actors just throughout history, just
CANNOT catch a break, huh?
If these laws seem restrictive, they are!
But the crackdown on the cycle plays pushed
the theater in new and more innovative directions,
while that whole vagrancy thing encouraged
actors to professionalize.
The earliest plays of the English Renaissance
predate all this licensing and vagrancy.
Two of the first English Renaissance plays
were comedies written in vernacular English.
They were modeled on the work of, surprise
surprise, Plautus and Terence!
But morality plays were an obvious influence,
too, and maybe also medieval farces.
Neoclassicism didn’t catch on in England
the way it did in Italy and in France, so
these English plays tend to be looser and
more episodic.
The earliest one is “Ralph Roister Doister,”
which was written in the 1540s by a schoolmaster
named Nicholas Udall.
The title character is a braggy dolt, kind
of like the Captain from the commedia dell-arte.
He falls in love with a virtuous widow, Christian
Custance, and tries to win her over, while
egged on by Matthew Merrygreeke, a clever
trickster type who owes a lot to the Vice
character from the morality plays.
Ralph gets tricked, beaten, and a rape almost
happens.
But then the widow marries her rich, honorable
suitor, Gawyn Goodluck, and it all ends happily.
Another early play is “Gammer Gurton’s
Needle” by an unknown author.
It was first performed in the early 1560s,
and it also derives most of its humor from
bodily harm.
Gammer Gurton has lost her sewing needle.
Diccon of Bedlam, a wandering fool and another
Vice type, tries to stir up trouble by claiming
that her next door neighbor, Dame Chat, took
it.
Everyone gets beaten up, including a curate–which
is sorta like a priests assistant–and the
needle is discovered when a servant is stabbed
in the butt.
Hilarious!
It was a simpler time, ok?
Wiseguy eh?!
I’m sorry,
Another early play tried to be all genres
to all spectators.
It was called “Cambises” for short.
Why “for short” you may ask?
Well the full title goes: “A lamentable
tragedy mixed ful of pleasant mirth, conteyning
the life of CAMBISES King of PERCIA, from
the beginning of his kingdome unto his death,
his one good deed of execution, after that
many wicked deeds and tirannous murders, committed
by and through him, and last of all, his odious
death by Gods Justice appointed, Doon in such
order as foloweth.”
I’d love to see the poster for that one.
It was written by the schoolmaster Thomas
Preston and mostly likely performed sometime
in the 1560s.
The episodic structure and the focus on good
versus evil link it closely with morality
plays, but also history plays.
The first tragedy on an English subject is
“The Tragedie of Gorboduc,” a play by
Thomas Norton and Thomas Sackville, first
performed in 1561.
Because it’s a tragedy, Seneca is the big
influence, but there’s some morality play
elements, too.
It’s written in blank verse, the meter that
he-who-shall-not-be-named-until-the-next-episode
uses, and also goes by the catchy title “Ferrex
and Porrex.”
The story goes like this:
Gorboduc is an ancient king of Britain who
decides to divide the realm between his two
sons, Ferrex and Porrex.
They fight, Porrex kills Ferrex, and so the
Queen stabs Porrex while he’s sleeping.
Then the people rebel, killing both Gorboduc
and the Queen.
Nobles rise up and kill most of the people.
Everything’s a huge mess, and the succession
is still unclear.
Now that’s what I call a tragedy.
Right, Yorick?
And yes, this obviously sounds a lot like
“King Lear,” but of course we aren’t
discussing “King Lear.”
Unless what I’m saying now counts.
DANGIT.
Early English Renaissance plays weren’t
staged in theaters, because freestanding permanent
theaters didn’t exist yet.
Not in England, anyway.
These plays were staged in gardens, banquet
halls, inn yards and schools.
But as acting became increasingly professionalized
and plays became increasingly popular, troupes
started to raise funds to build permanent
structures.
They couldn’t build them in the City of
London itself, because there was a belief
that play-going spread plague.
Plays and players were basically outlawed
in the city proper by the 1570s.
The first theater was probably the Red Lion,
which was built in Whitechapel, just outside
of the center of London, in 1567.
We don’t know much about it, except that
it had a pretty big stage, some kind of turret—and
that it was very badly constructed.
One of the only surviving documents about
the Red Lion is from a complaint by the owner,
John Brayne, against the carpenter who built
it.
The lawsuit over its poor construction dragged
on until 1578—which may have been longer
than the Red Lion itself survived.
A longer-lasting theater was called… drum
roll please…
The Theatre.
It was built in 1576 by the actor and businessman
James Burbage in a neighborhood full of gambling
dens and brothels, because, as we’ll discuss
in our episode on the closing of theaters,
they were considered pretty immoral as far
as structures go.
For a look at the theater The Theatre, the
first important Elizabethan playhouse, let’s
look at the Thoughtbubble:
The Theatre borrowed its design from inn yards
or maybe bear-baiting pits, which is exactly
what it sounds like.
In Elizabethan England, deciding what you
wanted to do for the evening was like, “HMMM
do I feel like watching a bunch of dogs try
to kill a bear, or do I feel like seeing a
play?
” The Theatre had a three-level gallery
structure on most sides, surrounding a thrust
stage and a bare-as-in-empty space in the
middle where penny-paying ticket holders could
stand.
If you paid another penny, you could move
to the galleries.
And if you had three pennies, you got a stool.
FAAAANNNNN-CY
The Theater was associated with the Lord Admiral’s
Men, and a bunch of the early plays by Ole
What Lights Through Yonder Window Shakes.
Eventually a dispute with the landlord led
Burbage to dismantle the theater and move
it across the river, where it became, dramatic
pause, the Globe.
These early theaters were open air, public
arenas.
They could seat as many as 2500 people—everyone
from slumming nobles to workingmen to the
poor.
Women came, too, although it wasn’t considered
respectable, so some wore disguises!
But there were no women on stage.
Boys played the female roles.
And Scenery wasn’t as advanced as it was
in Italy.
Scenes were set with some hanging cloths in
the back and maybe a few props.
Plays were held in the afternoon, to take
advantage of the natural light.
A lot of snacks were sold, and beer, too.
And if the audience didn’t like the play,
those snacks would be thrown!
Thanks, Thoughtbubble!
You wouldn’t throw snacks at me if you didn’t
like a thoughtbubble, would you Yorick?
HEY, NO.
BAD SKELLY.
I suppose I deserve this after the eyepoking
incident.
In 1576, the first indoor, private theater
appeared, Blackfriars Theatre.
It was located on the grounds of a former
Dominican Monastery.
It fell into disuse, and in 1596, a second,
fancier theater was built nearby, also by
James Burbage.
These indoor theaters seated about 750 people,
and since seats were more expensive they drew
a ritzier crowd.
Whether or not that meant ritzier crackers
were tossed at the talent, I’m not sure.
The plays they put on were thought to be wittier
and more sophisticated than those in the public
theaters, though, and they were initially
performed by companies of boys, because the
Renaissance and … child labor.
Who wrote these sophisticated plays for those
child laborers?
Well, they were written by a group of playwrights
who were later called the University Wits,
because unlike Billy Wiggleharpoon, they all
went to Oxford or Cambridge.
These snobs wrote sophisticated plays for
grown-up actors, too, including many that
are still performed today.
Basically these guys started with, and improved,
the early dramas we looked at, making them
better—truer, livelier, with more awesome
poetry.
They prepared the way for–ok,fine–Shakespeare,
WILLIAM SHAKESPEARE ... though they didn’t
always like him.
One of them called him an “upstart crow.”
Yeesh!
Get thee some milk of the poppy to relieve
the scorch from that Rennaissance Burn!
Among the University Wits were Thomas Kyd,
John Lyly, Robert Green, and Christopher Marlowe.
Thomas Kyd is best known for “The Spanish
Tragedy.”
It borrows from Seneca, helps kick off the
craze for revenge tragedy, and has a strong
influence on “Hamlet,”.
John Lyly wrote charming pastorals, which
probably inspired “As You Like It.”
Robert Green, wrote comedies and pastorals
and is best known for “Friar Bacon and Friar
Bungay,” which is a history play and a love
story and also a morality play with magicians
and a talking head.
YES, YOU ALSO ARE THAT, except you’re pretty
quiet...
And then there’s Christopher “Kit” Marlowe,
who led a very busy life before dying in a
tavern brawl before he was 30.
He went to Cambridge, where he earned a master's
degree.
He also worked for the Elizabethan government
in some secret capacity, maybe as a spy.
His plays are long and intense and full of
gorgeous, vivid blank verse which heavily
influenced Shakespeare.
Marlowe’s characters are ambitious.
Really ambitious.
They want to conquer the world or change it.
Or—as in the case of “Doctor Faustus,”
his most famous play—make a deal with the
devil that guarantees you a couple of decades
as the smartest and most powerful person on
earth.
His tragedies are tragedies of overreaching...
of characters who want too much and usually
get it, with disastrous consequences.
Since he’s a big ole deal, we’re gonna
be devoting our next three episodes to Shakespeare.
Also, Yorick insists.
Try to remember that Shakespeare doesn’t
come from nowhere.
Okay, yes, Stratford-upon-Avon, kind of is
nowhere.
But he doesn’t arise ahistorically, or come
from nowhere artistically.
He arrives in a theatrical culture that’s
already professionalized and thriving, in
a London of established troupes, competing
theaters, and eager beer-swilling, snack-throwing
audiences.
Who We’ll see plenty of next time.
Until then… compost those tomatoes… and
curtain!